we have a voicemail number that number
is two one nine two david p here's an
interesting question which relates to a
lot of different things we talked about
on the show take a listen
hi my name is james coffee scenario hi o
do good job thank you very you
you are very articulate when you form
your systems and senses is really well
on any wire you need to click on your
feet so to speak and that's a skill that
I'm just really struggling yet I'm
worried if it's a skill that you've
always had since you know you were a
little kid or if it's something you
really had to develop I would like to be
more than articulate when I speak on my
feet like you do yeah
and sound vaguely more intelligence but
I just want to give any advice or if
you've also had any struggles in the
past and you had to work on it or or if
it's just something that came natural to
you that's all thank you again thanks
her video bye here's the thing thinking
on your feet and being articulate
Anthony Fanta no actually has a really
good video about this on one of his
channels about how to be articulate
there's two parts to it
there is subject matter knowledge which
does matter okay and beyond that it's
just social comfort and comfort in
situations where one needs to think on
their feet and I have no question
whatsoever why I developed the comfort
and it's the jobs I held when from the
time that I was young when I was 14 I
started working at a laser tag place I
actually got a work permit from the
school superintendent who said David's
doing okay enough in school that I'm
going to allow him to have a job instead
of having to wait until he's 16 and I
worked at a laser tag place and I was
the person who had to deal with angry
parents because their kids equipment
their laser tag gun wasn't working and
handle payments and all of this stuff at
age 14 I had to be able to think on my
feet and deal with parents and kids and
people of all ages and college kids
coming in drunk to play laser tag and
whatever else I then worked at Circuit
City as a salesperson the now-defunct
electronics retail chain and I was
constantly dealing with angry people
because their TVs not working right or
though laptops not working right or
trying to sell extended service plans to
people and having to in the moment sort
of gauge what sort of
sales technique would best work it was
just that and that is how I it's just a
matter of practice and developing
confidence and social comfort sort of
the opposite of like a social anxiety is
what what I think most most helps there
and also having some subject matter
knowledge I think that there is no I
mean listen maybe there
they were probably recently read catch
me if you can by Frank a Bengali or a
banal if I'm not sure he pronounces his
last name he may have been a skilled
enough con man we're in a complete void
of subject matter knowledge he could
appear to be knowledgeable about
something for most people I think you
actually need to have the subject matter
knowledge in the area in which you are
trying to be articulate and and
well-spoken we've got a great bonus show
for you today a college board is
dropping its adversity score for
students after major backlash we will
talk about Kentucky Fried Chicken or I
guess now it just called KFC trying
plant-based chicken nuggets and wings in
the United States and we will also talk
about YouTube CEO saying that it is more
important than ever to let people upload
what it whatever they want to upload to
YouTube that's interesting and there is
a double meaning there that I am going
to talk about on today's bonus show
become a member at join pakman.com or a
patron at patreon.com slash david pakman
show to get instant access to today's
bonus show i'll speak to you then